[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily the request from
an accused killer of georgia beauty
queen
tara grinstead how ryan deuce could now
have state funds to help in his defense
and arrests made in the assault of u.s
capitol police officer brian siknik
who died of his injuries from the deadly
insurrection why the suspects are not
yet
facing murder charges plus jury
selection in the derrick chauvin trial
continues
a new motion to delay and move by the
defense after news of a 27 million
dollar settlement to george floyd's
family the judge now considering
and planning to re-question jurors law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
week two of jury selection is underway
in the derek chauvin trial
the former minneapolis cop charged with
murdering george floyd
law and crime's kim johnson is in front
of the hennepin county courthouse and
has the latest for us
that's right brian jury selection does
continue on this
day six of the murder trial for derrick
shoven and it's been
a busy day both with more jurors being
selected
as well as a motion by the defense to
change the venue of a court
citing claiming that last week's
announcement of that 27 million dollar
settlement given to the george floyd
family
could potentially impact jurors and
prospective jurors opinions of this case
i can tell you that the challenges of
finding jurors so far who have not
formed
strong opinions has already been evident
right off the bat the first juror
questioned monday immediately admitted
to hearing about last week's
wrongful death settlement on the radio
friday
she said that she assumed the city
settled out of court because
they couldn't prove their case in court
she also didn't think that she could be
a fair juror take a listen to what she
told judge peter cahill
i mean when i heard that i almost gasped
the amount
and so i i again i i would like to think
of myself as somebody who
tries to be impartial but i've just been
exposed to so much
information and and when that happened
it leaned me so far
to one side over the other that i
couldn't say under oath that i would be
that i'd be able to take that out of my
mind i'm going to excuse you from this
panel so
i appreciate your honesty and your
candor on this
now as for the two new jurors seated
monday one is a black man in his 30s
works in the banking industry he
supports black lives matter and says he
didn't think derek chovin
set out to intentionally harm anyone
that day and also said he wonders
why the other three officers didn't step
in the other juror seated monday is a
white
single mom in her 50s she works in
health care when asked about black lives
matter in her questionnaire she wrote
that she believes all lives matter
she says she has seen the video of
george floyd's death but couldn't watch
the whole thing because
it was quote too disturbing so to recap
where the jury
sits on day six we have five jurors who
are white
two are black one hispanic and one
describes herself
as mixed racially that's according to
how the court says that they identified
in their uh jury's survey six of the
jurors
are men three are women brian
thanks kim derek showman's defense team
has asked to delay the trial or
move it to another county after news
broke of the settlement
paid by the city of minneapolis to
george floyd's family long crimes
anjanet levy is here to explain what
happened
yeah brian news of that settlement
spread around the world
very quickly it made international news
and it really has
derek chovin's defense attorneys
concerned that it could convince jurors
that he's guilty
before any of the evidence has been
presented in court
i am gravely concerned with the news
that broke
on friday relevant to
the civil settlement in this case
derek chovin's attorney asked for
several remedies including delaying the
trial
moving it to another county giving the
defense more strikes to eliminate
jurors or sequestering the jurors
immediately
the fact that this came in the exact
middle of jury selection it it's
perplexing to me your honor
uh that whose idea it was
to release this information when it was
released george floyd's family appeared
at a press conference to announce the
settlement with their lawyers
and the mayor of minneapolis and members
of city council
including the son of minnesota attorney
general keith ellison
whose office is prosecuting chauvin in
terms of the
sort of inference that this was somehow
coordinated
uh by the state of minnesota it wasn't
you would agree it's unfortunate
wouldn't you that it's unfortunate that
we have
this reported all over the media when
we're in the midst of jury selection as
far as yeah it's
certainly not my preference your honor i
don't even know which way
that cuts if that cuts for us if that
cuts against us
you know some jurors cuts what's that
the problem is it cuts the state
objected to a continuance or increasing
the number of strikes allowed for the
defense
i wish people would city officials would
stop talking about this case so much but
at the same time i don't find any evil
intent that they are trying
to tamper with this criminal case
now judge cahill did not rule on the
defense request to continue the trial or
on the change of venue motion but
obviously he is moving forward with jury
selection at this time
he said he may dismiss more jurors for
cause but he is not going to increase
the number of strikes that
the defense has and he will call back
those first seven jurors for additional
questioning
to see whether or not that civil
settlement has impacted their ability to
be impartial
brian thanks angeanette joining us today
is civil rights and criminal defense
attorney melba pearson
and terry austin melbourne 27 million
dollars with 500
000 going to the community where floyd
died in
how big of a win is that in the civil
rights community and what does the
timing in relationship to the trial mean
to you
so this is a huge win in some
respects for the civil rights community
because number one
it showed that george floyd's life
mattered that the city knows that there
was no way they were going to be able to
win this case
other than to be able to do a settlement
and it also clearly sends a message to
the people watching everybody around the
country that
this that police brutality is not
something that's going to be stood for
and that there's really
there's real consequences now what i
think the civil rights folks want to see
most they want to see chauvin convicted
they want to see the other three
officers that were involved in this
incident in this murder
they want to see them held accountable
as well so the money on one hand is good
but the criminal accountability is what
everybody is
waiting for now the timing of the
settlement was very unfortunate i think
it's just a matter of and i agree with
the judge on this
i think it was just a matter of the city
and the civil side does not speak to the
prosecutors of the criminal side
so they had no real understanding of
the gravity of them releasing this in
the middle of jury selection
absolutely now terry i totally get the
change of venue uh
but like they said it's international
news where are they going to go
where they're not going to hear about
this settlement ryan there's
nowhere they can go where they're not
going to hear about this settlement so i
think that this continuing ask for
change of venue is never going to
succeed but i do think the judge is
listening to the defense as far as
hearing about the 27 million dollar
settlement and the fact that the judge
did say
he might consider calling back the seven
jurors and i listened today
the judge is asking the new prospective
jurors
about the fact that this settlement came
out so he's listening
absolutely and jeanette it was sort of a
quiet first week of jury selection but
that changed this week right
yeah that's right brian on the really
the day the jury selection was supposed
to begin and then it was delayed
that past monday there were a throng of
protesters there
a couple of different rallies held at
the courthouse then things tapered off
and the additional four days of the week
it was very quiet it was almost eerily
quiet
outside of the courthouse and one day it
was pouring down rain so you can
understand why people wouldn't be coming
out but today
a big group of protesters actually
returned and shut down part of the
street outside of the courthouse
but you know there were no incidents no
arrests made they were peaceful
but obviously they were coming out to
show their support for the prosecution
in this case as jury selection proceeds
and probably more of that as we get
closer and closer to that march 29th
date
thank you everyone still ahead on law
and crime daily the bold request from
one of the defendants
in the murder of a georgia buda queen
but first what an expert can and cannot
testify to
in the trial of derek chovin accused of
murdering george floyd
our legal analysis next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back it appears derek showman's
trial could come down to a battle of the
experts
angenette levy is here to tell us about
the arguments over one such expert
yeah brian nearly every day before jury
selection begins there are motions that
the defense
and the prosecution argue in front of
judge cahill
prosecutors are arguing to limit the
testimony of one key defense
expert experts in toxicology and
forensic pathology will testify for the
state and the defense
about what they believe caused george
floyd's death prosecutors asked to bar
dr david fowler from testifying about
some parts of his report
because he consulted with 13 other
experts in different fields
what the state is worried about is that
that dr fowler can't serve
as the mouthpiece for other experts
dr fowler is a former medical examiner
and works for the forensic panel in new
york
and the 13 experts he consulted signed
on to his report
ultimately that's what dr fowler does is
he
is investigating a death he is
submitting information to other experts
the defense likens it to a peer review
process and getting other experts to
weigh in to form one opinion
we would agree that your testifying
witness cannot
indirectly give the opinions of those
who are not present
absolutely okay they are his opinions
cause of death will be the central
question in the trial
hennepin county's medical examiner ruled
floyd's death a homicide
caused by cardiopulmonary arrest
complicating law enforcement subdual
restraint and neck compression chauvin
will argue that floyd died of a drug
overdose
in the end judge cahill ruled dr fowler
can testify
about his opinion about floyd's cause of
death
he will be limited in his testimony
to what falls within the expertise of a
forensic pathologist
anything beyond that even if it was one
of the other experts on this panel he
will not be allowed to talk about
there was also some discussion about the
prosecution wanting to call
a forensic psychiatrist to testify about
george floyd
possibly exhibiting some symptoms of
post-traumatic stress disorder
in those body camera videos the defense
argued against that and judge cahill
said that that forensic
psychiatrist could certainly testify
about floyd possibly exhibiting symptoms
of a panic attack or claustrophobia
but he would not or that expert would
not be able to testify
about ptsd because there was nothing in
the medical records to back up that
claim
brian thanks andrea here to discuss the
court's ruling as civil rights and
criminal defense attorney melba pearson
and terry austin terry off the top was
this the right ruling from the judge
can the expert give opinions based on
their expertise and not those he
consulted
you know i think we have the exact right
judge for this case
cahill is being very careful with his
decisions he's not eliminating any of
the expert but he
is saying that you are limited to
talking about
your area of expertise of course you can
be influenced by others
but at the end of the day you have to
talk about your area and here he said
the dr fowler is a forensic pathologist
he can talk about that and even though
he had a peer review
for this morbidity and mortality
conference
he has to limit his testimony to just
what he knows
and to his opinion so i think he's
making the right decision on this expert
and the others he's talked about as well
yeah melbourne kind of sounds like he's
just i don't know following the law i
can
talk about my expertise in criminal
defense but i can't talk about an
expertise in i don't know immigration
law
i don't have it now is this greatly
going to limit the defense's argument
or does this mean we're just going to
see a lot of experts testify
yeah i don't think that this is going to
limit the defense at all i think that
basically
they're now just going to it actually
helps them to a certain degree
because now they can put on more experts
and basically have
each expert talk about their narrow area
of expertise or what they worked on in
relation to this case
however what's going to be critical is
that the judge is going to have to keep
an eye on how many
experts they want to bring in so it's
not a situation where you have 20
defense experts
to counter one medical examiner and the
new experts they're bringing in are not
adding more value or adding more
information to help the jury make a
decision
as opposed to it just being a show of
force type of thing so the judge is
going to have to keep a very close eye
on that but i don't think it limits the
defense at all
no anjanette we went from seven to nine
jurors from the first week to now
starting the second week
how do you see the jury kind of shaping
up
you know brian i think we could have it
possibly a jury by the end of this week
at the
pace that things are moving we're just
going to have to wait and see
um but it's a very labor-intensive
process as we've seen over the last week
or so
they take about an hour to question
these jurors the judge is also
questioning the jurors he may dismiss
more of the jurors for cause because of
news of that civil settlement
but i think it's entirely possible we'll
have a jury by the end of the week
i'm not only hoping that we have a jury
by the end of the week but i'm hoping
that this judge decides
to have more alternates i know i keep
like going on and on about this but two
alternates in a case like this
that's crazy so we'll see how it's like
doesn't it
yeah yeah i mean the pandemic three
jurors come out and then backwards trial
but we'll see how this goes coming up on
law on crime daily
two men now charged with attacking an
officer killed in the capitol riot
plus an update in the murder of a
georgia beauty queen
one of the defendants he helped in his
representation does his request stand
the chance find out next
we're back one of the defendants charged
in the murder of a georgia beauty queen
is now entitled to state funds to help
in his representation
teacher and pageant competitor tara
grinstead died in october of 2005.
ryan duke is accused of killing her and
bearing her body
along with his friend co-defendant beau
dukes beau dukes pled guilty in 2019
to helping get rid of the body ryan duke
is being represented by private
attorneys
but they're working for free his defense
requested government money
to hire investigators and experts on his
behalf prosecutors objected
saying he chose not to be represented by
court appointed public defenders
georgia supreme court now says the
district court aired in siding with the
prosecution
the state's high court ruled that duke's
pro bono representation
entitles him to state funds in his
defense a trial date has yet to be set
back to discuss a state court's ruling
and civil rights and criminal defense
attorney melba pearson and co-host terry
austin
melbourne this is a perfect week to
discuss indigent defense as it's 58
years
since gideon view wainwright the
landmark case that created public
defenders like me
where do you fall in this debate of
private pro bono
attorney getting state funds to help
represent their client
well at the end of the day what it
always focuses on
is whether or not the defendant is
indigene whether or not the person has
any money and can fund their own defense
clearly even though it's a defense team
that's private and has a lot of
resources
the defendant in and of himself does not
have money to fund his own defense
so that is basically the textbook
definition of gideon and that's what
the the higher court looked at in making
this ruling
so i think that he is well within his
right because if you had a public
defender
or any other type of indigent uh defense
attorney that was handling this case
you know they would be entitled to get
money from the state to be able to
conduct the defense
so there's there's nothing different
about the scenario other than the fact
that these defense attorneys are doing
this
for free pro bono i think the court made
the right ruling
yeah terry they're pretty much looking
at gideon to decide this do you think
the state supreme court got it right
well not only is the state supreme court
right but melba's right as well i think
this was the right decision
if a defendant whose indigent has a
constitutional right to state-funded
experts
there's no reason this defendant should
not have that same
right only because he's using a pro bono
lawyer that makes no difference so it
was the right decision brian
yeah we'll see how this plays out and of
course if there's going to be more of
this situation
of private attorneys taking pro bono
clients and getting state funds
i don't know maybe it saves money maybe
it exhausts more money we'll see how
that plays out
when we come back months after the
deadly insurrection at the capitol
new arrests the arrested suspects
accused of spraying a fallen officer in
the face
the charges when we come back
welcome back a washington state woman is
accused of killing her baby two decades
ago
investigators say her dna helped lead to
her arrest
police in seattle reinvestigating the
death of a newborn baby
found at a gas station say the suspect
uploaded their own dna
to a database a grady surveillance image
from 1997
shows a woman detectives say dumped her
baby boy's body in a trash can
investigators believe the baby was born
alive in the gas station's bathroom
the baby's dna was uploaded into the
washington state crime lab
the case was reopened in 2018 and
investigators say they got a hit
to christine marine warren warren
reportedly opted to not make her data
private
she was arrested and is facing
second-degree murder
two suspects are facing charges for the
deadly assault of capitol police officer
brian siknik during the january 6
insurrection
the fbi says the tipster led them to
george pierre thanos and julian cater
the men are believed to have grown up
together in new jersey according to
court records
cater can be seen in a video posted on
social media
reaching into tanos's backpack and
asking for bear spray
then around 2 30 body worn cameras and
surveillance videos reportedly showed
three officers
including siknik reacting to a chemical
substance being sprayed in their eyes by
cater
cigna died from his injuries sustained
that day the two men are facing nine
charges of assault
conspiracy to injure and civil disorder
now but the interesting part here is
this case was investigated as a homicide
by a fire extinguisher
and now it's an assault with bear spray
is that odd or just how investigations
go
i think it's a bit odd but then again we
have not
had a insurrection slash riot
slash attempted coup in this country in
hundreds of years and certainly not at
our nation's capital
so i think that the investigators
wanted to make sure to get some charges
on the books
to be able to arrest these two
defendants and they always have the
option of being able to add
or change the indictment or the charging
document to add
homicide charges later but at least this
allows them to be taken into custody
and to start to face accountability for
their actions on that day
but as more information comes to light
as more informants come forward
as more witnesses come forward then the
case for
murder becomes a lot stronger and maybe
that's what the investigators are
betting on at this point
yeah i would agree terry for me i think
maybe the missing link
is the cause of death that's always
something that we're looking for in
these types of cases
as melbourne said could that potentially
come down the road with further
investigation
well brian that's exactly why they have
not charged murder here they don't have
that missing link the medical examiner
is going to have to come
out and say this was the cause of his
death and until they do that the
prosecution can't charge
thank you guys and thank you for joining
us here at law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you